When I was in seventh grade, I was at my friend Dave [? Berowi's ?] house. And we went to the fridge for a snack. And he opens up the door to the fridge. And inside was a six pack of beer. And I had never seen beer in real life, in someone's house. Beer was just something from TV. You know, it was just like one of those things from TV that was out there that never really showed up in the real life of anybody that you knew.
当我七年级的时候，我在朋友戴夫·[贝罗维]家。我们去冰箱找零食。他打开冰箱门，里面有六罐啤酒。我以前从未在现实生活中、在别人家里见过啤酒。啤酒对我来说只是电视里的东西。你知道，它就像电视里那种永远不会出现在你认识的任何人的现实生活中的事物一样。
And I say this knowing how this sounds, how sheltered this sounds. But my parents were Jews. And I grew up on this block in suburban Baltimore where everybody was Jewish. And just people didn't drink when I was a kid. I did not see booze in people's houses. But this was seventh grade. And I was getting off the block for the first time. And seeing this beer, I remember it seemed dangerous. It seemed actually dangerous.
说这话时，我知道这听起来有多么天真。但我父母是犹太人。我是在巴尔的摩郊区长大的，那条街上住的全是犹太人。我小时候人们根本不喝酒。我在别人家里没见过酒。但那是七年级。我第一次离开那个街区。看到这些啤酒，我记得它看起来很危险。看起来真的很危险。
I remember thinking the [? Berowis ?] have this secret, this dirty little secret. Mr. [? Berowi ?] suddenly seemed capable of anything. But at the same time, the [? Berowis ?] were really great. I used to go to the ocean with their family during the summer. They were great. And I remember I had to rearrange in my head all of my half-baked ideas about alcohol to accommodate the thought that normal people drink, which I guess is what happens when you see a little more of the world.
我记得当时心想，[贝罗维]一家有这个秘密，这个肮脏的小秘密。[贝罗维]先生突然显得什么事都干得出来。但同时，[贝罗维]一家人真的很好。夏天我常和他们全家去海边。他们很棒。我记得我必须在脑海中重新调整我对酒精的那些半生不熟的看法，以适应正常人也喝酒的想法，我想这就是当你多看一点世界时会发生的事情。
I was like the first bird among all my friends. And nobody could believe that I got visa to go to America.
我是我所有朋友中第一只“飞出来的鸟”。没人敢相信我拿到了去美国的签证。
Valentina was 24 when she left Odessa-- in the former Soviet Union-- to come work in the United States. And after two weeks here, she had a sudden and very urgent need to go to the store.
瓦伦蒂娜24岁时离开前苏联的敖德萨，来到美国工作。到这里两周后，她突然有一种非常迫切的需求要出门。
And I went to the supermarket to get what I need, my feminine hygiene products. And it took me probably long, long time to find the right aisle. And I saw the rows of tampons. Maxi, mini, super, with wings, without wings.
我去了超市买我需要的东西，我的女性卫生用品。我大概花了很长很长时间才找到正确的过道。我看到了成排的卫生棉条。大号、小号、超大号，有护翼的，没护翼的。
Got that? It was overwhelming.
听懂了吗？这让人不知所措。
Maxi, mini, super, with wings, without wings. And thinking, I don't know what they use it for. First, it was very interesting. Then it was confusing. And then it was sad. And then it was frustrated. It was a very, very sad experience for me.
大号、小号、超大号，有护翼的，没护翼的。我想着，我不知道她们用这个干什么。起初，这很有趣。然后，这让人困惑。接着，这让人感到悲伤。最后，感到挫败。那对我来说是一次非常、非常难过的经历。
She left the store without buying anything, went to the place she was staying, and cried.
她空手离开超市，回到住处，哭了。
And I couldn't ask for help because my American friends, they were still new to me. And I didn't want them to look at me like I'm from the forest or from a cave. I really wanted to go home. It made me feel very small.
我没法寻求帮助，因为我的美国朋友们对我来说还很新。我不想让他们觉得我像是从森林或山洞里出来的。我真的很想回家。这让我觉得自己很渺小。
Though you know, sometimes when the world gets bigger, it's great. One of the regular contributors to our program, Starlee Kine, tells this story about her dad. Starlee's family's house was so chaotic when she was growing up-- they never ate regular meals together. Nothing was normal-- that after she moved away from home, whenever she would fly back to see her family, she would actually stay with a friend, not with her parents.
虽然你知道，有时当世界变得更大时，那感觉很好。我们节目的常驻撰稿人之一斯塔莉·凯恩讲了关于她父亲的故事。斯塔莉在成长过程中，家里总是乱成一团——他们从不一起吃正餐。什么都不正常——以至于她离家后，每当她飞回去看望家人，她实际上都会住在朋友家，而不是父母家。
And her dad would come and hang out with her at her friend's house. And after her parents split up, she was staying at her friend Allison's.
她父亲会来她朋友家和她聚在一起。父母分居后，她一直住在朋友艾莉森家。
And usually when he comes over, he'll just kind of walk around, asking lots of questions. And he touches everything. And he'll pick up pencils, and pens, and anything that's lying around. Little objects on top of the mantel place. Kind of how they arranged their living room furniture.
他过来时通常会四处走动，问很多问题。而且他会触碰一切东西。他会拿起铅笔、钢笔，以及任何随手放的东西。壁炉架上的小物件。甚至还会摆弄他们客厅的家具。
And at Allison's house, she has an aquarium. In the living room is a huge aquarium with lots of fish. And they're all pretty and different kinds of fish. And the first time my dad ever came to Allison's house, he looked at this aquarium for like an hour. And I thought he was really into fish. Or something. I didn't understand what was going on.
艾莉森家有一个水族箱。客厅里有一个巨大的水族箱，里面有很多鱼。它们都很漂亮，而且种类繁多。我父亲第一次来艾莉森家时，他盯着那个水族箱看了一个小时。我以为他真的很喜欢鱼什么的。我不明白发生了什么。
And then he started asking Allison all these questions like, who feeds the fish in the house? And where's the fish food kept? And all these kinds of things. And Allison would be all, like, either I feed it, or my brother feeds it, or Ben feeds it, someone around. And my dad got really confused. And he was like, I don't understand. Wouldn't you over-feed it if you guys are all feeding the fish? And she'd be like, no. We just know who's fed it before. And he's like, I don't-- do you-- how do you commun--
然后他开始问艾莉森所有的问题，比如家里是谁喂鱼？鱼食放在哪？还有诸如此类的事情。艾莉森就会说，要么是我喂的，要么是我哥哥喂的，或者本喂的，周围的人喂的。我父亲感到非常困惑。他问，我不明白。如果你们都去喂鱼，不会把鱼撑死吗？她说，不会。我们只是知道之前是谁喂过了。他问，我不知道……你们……你们是怎么沟通的……
He just was really confused about how they communicated this information to each other. And then finally Allison was like, we just tell each other who's fed the fish. I talk to my brother. And that's how I know. And then my dad was totally blown away.
他对他们如何向彼此传达这个信息感到非常困惑。最后艾莉森说，我们只是告诉对方谁喂了鱼。我跟哥哥说一声。我就知道了。我父亲完全被惊呆了。
I realize that what my dad-- why he was staring at the fish tank was that he couldn't understand how a very simple thing like fish getting fed worked in a functional household. And it was like, as soon as she said that they talked to each other, my dad realized there was an entirely different way for families to function, which involved communicating basic things.
我意识到我父亲盯着鱼缸的原因是，他不明白在一个功能正常的家庭里，喂鱼这种简单的事情是如何运作的。这就好比，当她说他们会互相沟通时，我父亲意识到家庭运作的方式竟然完全不同，其中包括沟通基本事项。
You can travel to another continent to see how the rest of the world lives. Or you can do that sitting on a couch, in a house that's just ten minutes from your own.
你可以去另一个大洲看看世界其他地方是如何生活的。或者你也可以坐在沙发上，在离你家只有十分钟路程的地方体会到这一点。
I think it was hopeful. Because I think it's always when you discover that the world is bigger, or there's something new that you haven't known, like a different way of doing something, it's pretty exciting.
我觉得这充满希望。因为我认为每当你发现世界变大了，或者有什么你以前不知道的新事物，比如一种不同的做事方式时，总是非常令人兴奋的。
For today on our show, the Big Wide World, and how it's both exciting and frightening when you head out to discover the new things you hadn't known. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International.
今天我们的节目主题是“广阔的世界”，以及当你出发去探索那些你以前不知道的新事物时，它是如何既令人兴奋又令人恐惧的。这里是芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际发行。
I'm Ira Glass. Our show today in two acts. Act One, Teen Wolf Blitzer. Act Two, I've Got The Whole World in My Hands. In that act, a girl who can not see wanders around a place that she's never been and tries to figure out, not just if it's safe or dangerous, but at a much more basic level, where is she? Stay with us.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分为两幕。第一幕，少年沃尔夫·布利策。第二幕，我掌握着整个世界。在这一幕中，一个看不见东西的女孩漫步在一个她从未去过的地方，试图弄清楚的不仅是安全还是危险，而在一个更基本的层面上，她在哪儿？请留下来。
Act One, Teen Wolf Blitzer. Well here are the ways that Haider Hamza was like lots of teenagers. He wanted to separate from his parents. He wanted to get out in the world. He wanted to try things that his parents never tried. Only he did this against a very dramatic backdrop. He grew up in embassies all over Europe and Africa. His father was a diplomat. And they were Iraqi. So his father was a diplomat for the Iraqi government, back before the United States invaded Iraq.
第一幕，少年沃尔夫·布利策。海德尔·哈姆扎和很多青少年一样。他想脱离父母。他想进入世界。他想尝试父母从未尝试过的事情。只是他在一个非常戏剧性的背景下做了这些。他在欧洲和非洲各地的使馆长大。他父亲是一名外交官。他们是伊拉克人。所以在他父亲在萨达姆执政前，他是伊拉克政府的一名外交官。
So when Haider was little they would live in all these different places. And then when he turns 13, the family moves back to Iraq. And the international embargo was in effect. And Saddam Hussein was in power. And it took some getting used to.
所以海德尔小时候住过很多不同的地方。当他13岁时，全家搬回了伊拉克。当时国际禁运已经生效。萨达姆·侯赛因掌握实权。这需要一些时间来适应。
And then, in spring 2001, when Haider was 16, three officials from Saddam Hussein's Ministry of Information came to his high school in what was basically a casting call. They wanted students. They wanted outgoing, personable students-- especially students with good foreign language skills-- who would be willing to do a job for the Ministry of Information, a job where they would be representing Iraq on the world stage.
2001年春天，海德尔16岁时，萨达姆·侯赛因新闻部的三名官员来到他的高中，进行了一场选角。他们想要学生。他们想要外向、讨人喜欢的学生——尤其是外语能力好的学生——愿意为新闻部工作，代表伊拉克在世界舞台上发声。
So Haider went out for it. And he got hired. And he was in that job three years later-- by this time he was 19-- when the US invasion was looming, which is when our story begins. Gideon Yago tells more.
海德尔去应聘了。他被录用了。三年后，也就是他19岁时，美国入侵战争一触即发，我们的故事也由此开始。吉迪恩·亚戈报道了更多细节。
Haider Hamza was a professional teenager. This is how his job worked. Say a group of Japanese dignitaries were coming to Iraq. The Ministry of Information would call Haider and a couple of other teenagers to come and be the face of Iraqi youth at a get together. Or some foreign journalists would show up and want to do a story about Iraqi teens. Well, the Ministry of Information would assign Haider to be the subject.
海德尔·哈姆扎是个“职业青少年”。他的工作是这样的。假设有一群日本政要来到伊拉克。新闻部会叫海德尔和其他几个青少年去参加聚会，作为伊拉克青年的门面。或者一些外国记者出现，想写一篇关于伊拉克青少年的报道。新闻部就会指派海德尔担任报道对象。
Or Haider would work as a fixer, helping reporters to find other people to interview-- other kids-- people who wouldn't say anything too bad about the regime. He was part of Saddam's propaganda machine. And he liked it.
或者，海德尔会担任“中间人”，帮助记者寻找其他人来采访——其他孩子——那些不会对政权说坏话的人。他是萨达姆宣传机器的一部分。而且他很喜欢。
For me it was kind of cool. Because I was 19. I got to skip all classes at school. I didn't have to go to school. All I needed to go was just to go to my professor and say, well, I'm wanted at the Ministry of Information. And Saddam's son, Uday, was the one in charge on most of the media in Iraq at the time. So I was like, oh, Mr. Uday wants us at the Ministry. And he'd go, of course, of course, just go ahead. And I kept getting straight A's. And I hardly went to school.
对我来说这很酷。因为我19岁。我可以逃避所有的学校课程。我不必去学校。我只需要去找教授说，我在新闻部有任务。萨达姆的儿子乌代当时负责伊拉克的大部分媒体。所以我就说，哦，乌代先生要求我们在新闻部。他就说，当然，当然，你去吧。我一直拿全A。但我几乎不去上学。
And the salary was good. I was making more money than my dad. And my dad was an ambassador for, like, 40 years. And I had this badge that said Ministry of Information. And the thing is, most of the employees of the Ministry of Information actually work for the intelligence. And they take it as a cover, like for the Mukhabarat, which is the intelligence service in Iraq. So when I show it, people think I work for the intelligence service. So I wouldn't stand in any lines. I wouldn't wait anywhere.
而且工资不错。我赚得比我父亲还多。我父亲当了40年大使。我有一个挂牌写着新闻部。关键是，新闻部的大多数员工实际上为情报部门工作。他们将其作为掩护，比如为情报局，也就是伊拉克的情报服务机构。所以当我展示它时，人们以为我在为情报部门工作。所以我不必排队。我不需要等待。
At 19?
19岁时？
At 19. Yeah. So I loved the attention, just like any 19-year-old would. And we got to stay at five-star hotels, because whenever a delegation of journalists comes to visit the country, they would take us to stay with them at the hotel and just guide them around. And basically also make sure they don't interview someone they're not supposed to interview, or they don't say something they're not supposed to say, or any of that. So I enjoyed it. I quite enjoyed it.
19岁时。对。所以我喜欢这种关注，就像任何19岁的人一样。我们可以住在五星级酒店，因为每当有记者代表团来访，他们就会带我们和他们住在一起，引导他们四处参观。基本上还要确保他们不采访不该采访的人，或者不乱说话。所以我很享受。我非常享受。
At first, Haider's job was just part-time. But by 2002, more and more journalists were showing up in Baghdad asking questions about the war that was looming. And the Ministry needed Haider to work full time. He wound up in a lot of news stories about youth in Iraq, and on several panels with American students, answering their questions.
起初，海德尔的工作只是兼职。但到了2002年，越来越多的记者出现在巴格达，询问有关战争的迫近问题。新闻部需要海德尔全职工作。他最终出现在许多关于伊拉克青年的新闻报道中，并参加了几个与美国学生的座谈会，回答他们的问题。
Hi, and welcome. I'm Vanessa Rae, and today we're participating in a historic discussion between the young people of two countries on the brink of war. We're building a bridge to Baghdad. And in New York City--
你好，欢迎收看。我是凡妮莎·雷，今天我们正在参加两个处于战争边缘的国家年轻人之间的历史性讨论。我们在建立一座通往巴格达的桥梁。而在纽约市——
This is from a TV program called Bridge to Baghdad. Just before the invasion, a New York group called Downtown Community Television connected two groups of students via satellite. Iraqi and American kids talking war. The Iraqi group includes a couple of Ministry of Information plants, including Haider. The Americans sit in comfy couches near glass windows overlooking the New York skyline. The Iraqis are on fold-out chairs in a Baghdad art gallery, where, just off-camera, stands a pack of Ministry of Information minders and Ba'ath Party officials.
这是来自一个叫“通往巴格达之桥”的电视节目。入侵前夕，纽约一个名为“市区社区电视”的组织通过卫星连接了两组学生。伊拉克和美国孩子谈论战争。伊拉克团队包括几个新闻部的卧底，包括海德尔。美国人坐在俯瞰纽约天际线的玻璃窗旁的舒适沙发上。伊拉克人在巴格达一个艺术画廊的折叠椅上，摄像机外站着一群新闻部的监视人员和复兴党官员。
Well, hi there, dudes. My name is Haider. And I won't say anything else, because I'm really, really eager to rock and roll. What Saddam wanted to do is to show a different image of Iraq that was sort of portrayed in the West and the US, an image of a backward country, and people are oppressed, and uneducated, and people don't have any freedom. And our policy was mostly to stay as social as possible, and avoid being political as much as possible.
嘿，伙计们。我叫海德尔。我不说别的了，因为我真的非常非常渴望摇滚起来。萨达姆想要展示的是一种与西方和美国所描绘的完全不同的伊拉克形象，而不是一个落后、被压迫、未受过教育、没有自由的国家。我们的策略大多是尽可能保持社交，并尽可能避免政治。
How are things resolved within the government when there are differences of opinion?
政府内部有分歧时，事情是如何解决的？
Can we change the subject a bit? Do you like sports, any of you? Do you--
我们能换个话题吗？你们喜欢运动吗？你们……
The most striking thing about the footage is how earnestly the American teens ask questions that no Iraqi could ever answer without risking jail time, and how uncomfortable the Iraqi teens look when trying to answer.
镜头里最引人注目的事情是，美国青少年真诚地问着那些伊拉克人若不冒坐牢风险就永远无法回答的问题，而伊拉克青少年在试图回答时显得多么不安。
Are you guys-- are you able to find a new leader if you wanted one?
你们……如果你们想要一个新的领导人，你们能找到吗？
We feel that this person really represents that. So we are supporting him, of course.
我们觉得这个人真的代表了这一切。所以我们当然支持他。
Haider generally didn't spend a lot of time dwelling on the bad things that Saddam's regime had done. Sure, Saddam had run Iraq with an iron fist. But this didn't seem all that different from the leaders of Syria, or Saudi Arabia, or lots of other countries in the region to Haider. And living in Iraq, he didn't exactly hear details about Saddam's atrocities. People didn't talk about those things. They were rumors, vapors, hard to be sure of.
海德尔通常不会把时间花在反思萨达姆政权所做的坏事上。当然，萨达姆以铁腕统治伊拉克。但这对海德尔来说似乎与叙利亚、沙特阿拉伯或其他地区的领导人没什么不同。生活在伊拉克，他并没有真正听到萨达姆暴行的细节。人们不谈论这些事情。它们只是传言、虚幻，很难确定真实性。
Meanwhile, every time he turned on a TV or opened a textbook, there he was, smiling benevolently. Papa Saddam. Like a member of your family. Even though they were just teens, Haider and the other kids at the Ministry of Information got treated like professionals. Before press appearances, they'd be exhaustively prepped, sometimes for days.
同时，每次他打开电视或打开教科书，萨达姆就在那里，慈祥地微笑着。萨达姆爸爸。就像你家庭的一员。尽管他们只是青少年，海德尔和新闻部的其他孩子还是被当作专业人士对待。在面对媒体之前，他们会接受详尽的培训，有时长达数天。
They would sit us in a room. And we'd have all these different professors, and intelligence officers, and diplomats, and a psychiatrist as well, actually. He came to tell us about human psychology, and what to say, and what not to say, and our facial expressions, how they should be.
他们会把我们带到一个房间。我们有所有的教授、情报官员、外交官，实际上还有一个精神科医生。他来告诉我们关于人类心理学，什么该说，什么不该说，我们的面部表情应该是怎样的。
And they gave us sheets. And we did exams. And how to answer-- if we're going to be asked about Halabja, how to avoid talking about the invasion of Kuwait, how to avoid talking about mass graves, and all this kind of stuff that we wouldn't dare to talk about. So for me it was very thrilling that I could actually have a conversation with an Iraqi official about these things, because I was not even allowed to talk with this with my parents at home. It was like a taboo.
他们发给我们清单。我们进行考试。怎么回答——如果我们被问到哈拉卜贾（大屠杀），怎么避免谈论入侵科威特，怎么避免谈论万人坑，以及所有这些我们根本不敢谈论的事情。所以对我来说，能和伊拉克官员谈论这些事情非常令人兴奋，因为我甚至不被允许在家里和父母谈论这些。这就像是一个禁忌。
Would you say-- do you think it's fair to say that your job was sort of as a professional-- I don't want to say actor, but professional kind of representative, mouthpiece?
你会说——你认为你的工作可以算作是职业——我不想说演员，但你是那种职业代表，喉舌吗？
I was a diplomat.
我是一名外交官。
You were a diplomat. That's how you view yourself.
你是外交官。你是这样看待自己的。
Yeah.
是的。
You were a 19-year-old diplomat on behalf of Saddam.
你是一个代表萨达姆的19岁外交官。
Yeah. My father was an ambassador. So I was like, OK, I'm a little him. I'm also a diplomat. I'm doing what he's doing. Because he spent all his life. My father was--
是的。我父亲是大使。所以我就像是，好的，我是个小号的他。我也是外交官。我在做他做的事情。因为他花了一辈子。我父亲是——
Lying? Spinning? Sorry.
撒谎？粉饰？抱歉。
Well, no. That's what politicians do. But he--
嗯，不。这就是政客做的事情。但他——
What do diplomats do?
外交官做什么？
They sort of dress up the truth, and make it look nice, and make it friendly. I think it's less mean, less evil, than what politicians do.
他们包装真相，使其看起来很好，很友好。我认为这比政客做的坏事少，没那么邪恶。
Haider's father used to tell Haider being a diplomat was the safest way to work inside the regime. If you're in the Foreign Service, he'd say, you can live abroad, and they can't monitor you too carefully. And they can't ask you to do things too terrible. The worst thing they can ask you to do is lie. Haider's dad had been a diplomat for 40 years and for four different governments. Monarchs, military coups, the Ba'ath party, and then Saddam. But despite-- or maybe because of-- this, he was totally opposed to his son's new job at the Ministry of Information.
海德尔的父亲曾告诉海德尔，当外交官是政权内部最安全的工作。他说，如果你在外交部门，你可以住在国外，他们无法过于密切地监视你。他们也不能要求你做太可怕的事情。他们能要求你做的最坏的事情就是撒谎。海德尔的父亲当了40年外交官，为四个不同的政府工作过。君主、军事政变、复兴党，然后是萨达姆。但尽管——或者也许正因为——如此，他完全反对儿子在新闻部的新工作。
Because he thought I was very naive, that I would do anything they asked me to. So they might ask me to do something that's going to hurt him, but I would still do it. He would say, listen, this is not a rational government you're dealing with. It's not about what you do. You can get in trouble even though you are doing everything right.
因为他觉得我非常天真，我会做他们要求我做的任何事。所以他们可能会要求我做一些会伤害他的事，但我还是会做。他会说，听着，你面对的不是一个理性的政府。这不是关于你做什么。即使你一切都做对了，你也会惹上麻烦。
He was worried about you becoming an out-and-out intelligence agent.
他担心你成为一个彻底的情报特工。
And that. He was worried about me becoming arrogant. He was worrying about me becoming a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] person. He was worrying about me becoming Saddam-ish, basically.
还有那个。他担心我会变得傲慢。他担心我会成为一个[听不清]的人。他担心我会变得像萨达姆一样，基本就是这样。
Right.
没错。
That's what he was worried about. And he was worried about me getting killed.
这就是他担心的。而且他担心我被杀。
Haider tuned his father out. He was 19, and, like most self-respecting teenagers, felt that he could handle making decisions on his own. But the Ministry of Information gig didn't just creep his father out.
海德尔没理他父亲。他19岁了，和大多数有自尊的青少年一样，觉得他自己能处理决断。但新闻部的差事不仅让他父亲感到恐惧。
I remember my best friend at the time, he didn't hang out with me anymore. Because he said, listen, you're going to get in trouble one day. And I don't want to be driven down with you as well.
我记得当时我最好的朋友，他不跟我玩了。因为他说，听着，你迟早会惹上麻烦的。我不想和你一起倒霉。
What does that mean, you were going to get in trouble?
惹上麻烦是什么意思？
Well, it means that on one of the shows or one of the interviews I'm going to say something stupid. Or I'm going to slip, and say something I'm not supposed to say. And then-- And I think something close to that happened.
嗯，意思是说在某个节目或采访中，我会说蠢话。或者我会说漏嘴，说了一些我不该说的话。然后——我觉得差不多就是这样了。
I remember I was interviewed by ABC Australian. And at the time, they did a whole documentary. They would follow me around. And we would go to a football match. And they would film me at a football match with my friends, and stuff like that. And I think it was at the stadium, they were asking me, what do you think of Saddam? And I've seen Saddam. I met him once back then.
我记得我接受了澳大利亚广播公司的采访。当时，他们做了一整部纪录片。他们跟着我到处走。我们会去参加足球赛。他们会拍我在足球赛上和朋友在一起，诸如此类。我想是在体育场，他们问我，你觉得萨达姆怎么样？我见过萨达姆。当时我见过他一次。
And they said, what do you think of Saddam? And I just posed. And I said, I think he is very polite. And they said, and? I was like, that's it. And it's like, what do you mean, that's it? It's like, very polite? Is that all you can say about him? Then they said, well, is he, like, the best?
他们说，你觉得萨达姆怎么样？我就摆个姿势。我说，我觉得他很有礼貌。他们说，然后呢？我说，没了。他们说，什么叫没了？就这样？很有礼貌？这是你对他能说的所有话吗？然后他们说，嗯，他是最好的吗？
And I said, well, no one is perfect. He's not a prophet or anything. So he definitely has some merits and demerits just like any other person. And I kept it to that. I thought that was not offending anyone. But people disagreed back in the office. And they said, how dare you say that he's just like any other person. He's not. He's Saddam.
我说，没有人是完美的。他不是先知或什么的。所以他肯定有优点也有缺点，就像任何其他人一样。我坚持这样说。我以为这没冒犯任何人。但在办公室，人们不同意。他们说，你怎么敢说他就像任何其他人一样。他不是。他是萨达姆。
Haider spent a night in detention answering intelligence officers' questions about his relationship with the reporter and his feelings about Saddam. But maybe because the war was looming and there were bigger fish to fry, all Haider got was a reprimand. He went back to work at the Ministry.
海德尔在拘留所待了一晚，回答情报官员关于他与记者的关系以及他对萨达姆感受的问题。但也许是因为战争临近，有更重要的事情要处理，海德尔只得到了一个训诫。他又回到了新闻部工作。
In the days leading up to the invasion, Haider spent most of his time at the Ministry. School, classes, family and friends all took the backseat. Haider filled his days doing interviews, hosting delegations, and working on songs and poems for Iraqi youth radio. Overseeing his work was Dr. Huda Ammash. Her nickname when she wound up on the coalition's deck of cards a few weeks later was Dr. Germ, for the work that she'd done in the development of Iraq's biological weapons program.
在入侵前的日子里，海德尔大部分时间都在新闻部。学校、课程、家人和朋友都退居二线。海德尔每天都在做采访、接待代表团，为伊拉克青年广播电台制作歌曲和诗歌。监督他工作的是胡达·阿马什博士。几周后，当她出现在联军的扑克牌（通缉令）上时，她的绰号是“细菌博士”，因为她在伊拉克生物武器项目发展中所做的工作。
But to Haider, she was a kindred spirit. Every day, she helped him and the rest of the Ministry of Information's junior league craft their messages and toe the party line. Working with her, Haider felt important and safe.
但在海德尔看来，她是灵魂伴侣。每天，她都帮助他和新闻部的其他青年队员构建信息并紧跟党纪。和她一起工作，海德尔感到重要且安全。
I have to confess I was enjoying this for a while, that I forgot how serious this is. And that's the other thing. We didn't feel there was a war. I remember until five days before the war, I had an exam at school. And I went to school and had my exam. We still went to school every day. There was still running water, electricity, and phone lines. People didn't leave. We didn't see anyone packing and leaving.
我必须承认我有一段时间很享受，我忘了这有多严重。这是另一件事。我们感觉不到有战争。我记得直到战前五天，我还在学校有考试。我每天照常上学。还有自来水、电力和电话线。人们没有离开。我们没看到任何人打包离开。
I believe until two or three days before the war, I thought, the US is not going to invade. And it's because I was close to all-- well not close, but I was around many senior officials of the government. And I think most of them believed that it's not going to happen. They believed it was just a threat. Russia and France would never allow that. They'll take care of us. And no, they'd give a warning to Saddam if it gets too serious. And that they can strengthen the sanctions, or impose more, or whatever, but that's going to be it. They're not going to actually invade.
我相信直到战前两三天，我都在想，美国不会入侵的。因为我接近所有的——好吧，不是接近，但我在政府许多高级官员身边。我认为他们大多数人相信这不会发生。他们相信这只是威胁。俄罗斯和法国绝不会允许那样。他们会关照我们。不，如果情况变得严重，他们会给萨达姆警告。他们会加强制裁，或者施加更多制裁，或者什么，但仅此而已。他们不会真正入侵。
But I think it was three days before the war, it was the last time I met with Dr. Germ. It was the last radio show we did. And when we were leaving, she said, where is your family? And I said, we're all still in Baghdad. And she said, take them out. And I was like, well, why? And she said, just take them out. They are coming. So take them out.
但我认为是在战前三天，那是我最后一次见到“细菌博士”。那是我们做的最后一次广播节目。我们要走的时候，她说，你的家人在哪里？我说，我们都还在巴格达。她说，带他们走。我问，为什么？她说，带他们走就行。他们要来了。所以带他们走。
And I think that was when I believed it's going to happen. It was that moment when she said that. I said, OK. It sort of took me out of the whole world of having fun, and talking to the media, and having cameras around me, and showing off, and walking out with my badge, and all that fun.
我想那就是我相信战争会发生的时候。正是她说话的那一刻。我说，好的。这似乎把我从那个充满乐趣、与媒体交谈、有摄像机围绕、炫耀、带着徽章四处走动、以及所有那些快乐的世界里拉了出来。
That night, Haider relayed to his parents what Dr. Ammash had told him. It was time to get out of Baghdad. Haider's father knew a place where they could lay low. There was a farmhouse four hours north of the city. It was a good place for the family-- Haider, his parents, and three siblings-- to wait and see what would happen next. Grudgingly, Haider climbed into the family car and left.
那天晚上，海德尔把阿马什博士的话转达给了父母。是离开巴格达的时候了。海德尔的父亲知道一个可以躲藏的地方。在城北四个小时车程外有一个农场。这对全家——海德尔、父母和三个兄弟姐妹——来说是个等待观察接下来发生什么的好地方。海德尔极不情愿地上了家里的车离开了。
We went there. There was no electricity, of course. And there was no running water. It was totally different. And it was hot. At the time it was getting hot. It was in April or March. And there were all these mosquitoes, I remember, because it was a farm. It was one night I spent there.
我们去了那里。当然没有电。也没有自来水。这完全不同。而且很热。当时天气开始变热。是在四月或三月。我记得蚊子很多，因为那是农场。我在那里待了一个晚上。
When I left I didn't tell any of my friends. So I got up, and I walked up to my dad, and I said, I can't stay here. I'm going back. And he was like, what are you talking about? I was like, we still have shows scheduled. We still have interviews on schedule. And I want to be part of that. I don't want to be living in a farm with a bunch of horses and cows.
我离开时没告诉任何朋友。所以我起床，走到我父亲面前说，我不能待在这里。我要回去。他说，你在说什么？我说，我们还有预定的节目。我们还有安排好的采访。我想参与其中。我不想和一群马和牛住在一个农场里。
He said, you're out of your mind. You're not going to go back. You're going to die. We are so lucky. We should be thankful that we made it here. We're going to stay here until this whole thing is over.
他说，你疯了。你不能回去。你会死的。我们太幸运了。我们应该庆幸我们到了这里。我们要待到这一切结束为止。
I went back to my mom and said, I'm leaving. She knows that I can not handle it there. She wasn't-- I mean, it was horr-- It was not a way to live. You have to sleep on the floor. And you have no electricity. They didn't even have a bathroom. It was like they had something that they called a bathroom, which was like you have to walk forever out in the middle of nowhere. And I was like, I can't live like that. I'm a celebrity. I am not going to live like that.
我回到我母亲身边说，我要走。她知道我在那里待不住。她不是——我是说，那太可怕了……那根本不是人过的日子。你必须睡在地板上。没有电。他们甚至没有厕所。就像他们有叫厕所的东西，但你必须走到荒郊野外的老远。我说，我不能那样生活。我是名人。我不会那样生活。
You're used to being in cars and having a badge.
你习惯了坐车和带着徽章。
It was funny. It was very odd. I believed there was a war coming. And I believed truly that it was the safest place to be, probably, if the war was going to happen. But I didn't want that. I didn't want to be in the safest place and not have any stories to tell afterwards. I was like, but I believe this whole thing is going to be over one time, and that I'm going to meet back, and they're going to say, OK, tell us how was the time in the war? What am I going to say? That I spent it with cows and sheep in the middle of nowhere? I was like, no.
这很滑稽。非常奇怪。我相信战争要来了。而且我确实相信如果战争发生的话，那可能是最安全的地方。但我不想那样。我不想待在最安全的地方，事后却没有任何故事可讲。我想，但我相信这一切总有一天会结束，当我再见到别人时，他们会说，好的，告诉我们战争期间是怎么回事？我要说什么？我是在荒郊野外和牛羊一起度过的？我说，不。
You were going to need some stories to tell.
你需要一些故事来讲。
Exactly. I said, I can do better than that. I mean, it was that many things else, of course. But that came across my mind as well, I have to say. So my dad was like, I'm not driving back to Baghdad. And I have young siblings. And he said, I'm not taking your siblings through this. If you're crazy, you have to face that alone. You don't have to let your siblings face that with you.
准确地说。我说，我可以做得更好。我是说，当然还有很多别的原因。但我也想到了这一点，我必须说。所以我父亲说，我不会开车回巴格达。我有年幼的兄弟姐妹。他说，我不会带着你的兄弟姐妹去冒险。如果你疯了，你得独自面对。你不必让你的兄弟姐妹跟你一起面对。
So I said, OK. I'll just take a cab. But there were no cabs around. So I had to walk for half an hour or so until I got to the closest house. And there was a farmer there with a pickup truck. And I said, would you take me to Baghdad? At the time I paid him, it was about $13. But in Iraq, $13 is a lot of money. And he said, OK, I'll drive you. Just one way. I'll drive you. So I go, OK. So I went, I packed.
所以我说，好的。我会打车。但周围没有出租车。所以我不得不走了一个半小时左右，直到到达最近的房子。那里有个农民，有一辆皮卡。我说，你能带我去巴格达吗？当时我付给他大约13美元。但在伊拉克，13美元是一大笔钱。他说，好的，我送你。只送一程。我送你。我说，好的。所以我去打包了。
My dad wouldn't even see me off. He was really angry that I'm doing this. But I got in, and I drove back. And I drove directly to the radio station, because at the time there was a show ongoing. And I saw my group and stuff. And I saw everyone. And everyone was like, so what are you guys doing? And they said, oh, we're all leaving.
我父亲甚至不送我。他对我做这件事真的很生气。但我上了车，开车回去了。我直接开车去了广播电台，因为当时正在进行节目。我看到了我的团队什么的。我看到了每个人。每个人都问，你们在干什么？他们说，哦，我们要走了。
I was like, where are you leaving? They said, we're leaving Baghdad. Because we all believed that the war was going to happen in Baghdad. It was going to be sieged for like months. And Saddam might even use chemical weapons. Because we didn't know if he owned them or not. So all my friends said, oh, we're leaving. I said, but now? I just came back.
我说，你们去哪？他们说，我们要离开巴格达。因为我们都相信战争会发生在巴格达。它会被围困几个月。萨达姆甚至可能使用化学武器。因为我们不知道他是否拥有它们。所以我所有的朋友都说，哦，我们要离开。我说，但现在？我刚回来。
So I realized I just made a mistake by coming back. I should have just stayed there. And all of a sudden, the life of cows and sheep didn't look so bad. And maybe that was the best option, and I should go back.
所以我意识到我刚回来就犯了个错误。我应该待在那里的。突然之间，与牛羊同住的生活看起来也不坏。也许那是最好的选择，我应该回去。
So I called the driver. I was like, I want you to drive me back to that farm. And this time I had to pay $30, because it was getting serious. And no one would go anywhere. Everyone was busy with his own family. I got down, and I went to the family, the farm. And I was like, I'm back. I'm taking my stuff down. And he said, no. I was like, what? He said, your parents just left-- went back to Baghdad-- because they couldn't be away from you. And there were no phones.
所以我给司机打了电话。我说，我要你送我回那个农场。这次我得付30美元，因为情况越来越严重。没有人愿意去任何地方。每个人都在忙着自己的家庭。我到了，我去了农场。我说，我回来了。我要把东西搬下来。他说，不。我说，什么？他说，你父母刚离开——回巴格达了——因为他们无法离开你。那里没有电话。
He said, they just left. They just went to Baghdad. Your dad didn't sleep all night. He was crying all night, actually. And he thought you were going to be trapped. And he said, the family is not going to be in two different locations. All the family will be together. So this morning-- about two hours ago-- your family went back to Baghdad because of you.
他说，他们刚走。他们回巴格达了。你父亲整晚没睡。他整晚都在哭。他以为你会陷入危险。他说，全家不能分开在两个地方。一家人要在一起。所以今天早上——大约两小时前——你家人因为你回巴格达了。
I actually felt, I felt like [BLEEP] at the time. I felt-- I don't know. I felt like nothing, you know. I was like, what am I doing? They saw me. I almost had a breakdown. So they took me inside. And they were just talking. And the guy, the owner of the house, is an older man. And he was like, listen, your dad is definitely concerned about your life more than he's concerned about his own. But just go back and be with your family.
我当时感觉简直像[消音]。我感觉……我不知道。我觉得自己像个废物。我心想，我在干什么？他们看见我了。我几乎崩溃了。所以他们把我带进去。他们只是在说话。那个人，房子的主人，是一位老人。他说，听着，你父亲关心你的生命肯定胜过关心他自己的。但回去和你家人在一起吧。
I said, what if I go back and they come back here again? And he he was like, no, it was just broadcasted on the news that people are allowed to get in the city but not out of the city. So you're going to be able to go back. They're not going to be able to leave anymore. And that's what I did. I went back. I was praying, all the way, that I'd find them and that they're not going to be angry. So I went back home. And I saw their car was parked outside. So I knew they were there. And my mom was outside in the garage waiting. And she was holding prayer beads at the time. And she was just praying and stuff. I saw her. And I came down. She really hugged me. And she was crying. And she was like, never do this again.
我说，如果我回去，而他们又回到这里怎么办？他就像，不，新闻里刚播报人们可以进城，但不能出城。所以你能回去的。他们再也出不来了。这就是我所做的。我回去了。我一路上都在祈祷，能找到他们，希望他们别生气。所以我回家了。看到他们的车停在外面。所以我知道他们在那里。我母亲在车库外等着。她手里拿着念珠。她在祈祷。我看到了她。我走过去。她用力抱住我。她哭了。她说，永远别再做这种事了。
Haider's father was more reserved. He gave his son the silent treatment at first. Ignoring his advice about the Ministry of Information job was one thing. But coming back to Baghdad? Their family's house was close to three major military targets-- the Baghdad airport, Iraq's national security headquarters, and one of Saddam's main palaces. The whole neighborhood was being evacuated. All the major roads were closed. And now, getting out of the city would be tough.
海德尔的父亲更加内敛。起初他给儿子冷处理。不听他关于新闻部工作的建议是一回事。但回到巴格达？他们家的房子靠近三个主要的军事目标——巴格达机场、伊拉克国家安全总部和萨达姆的主要宫殿之一。整个社区都在撤离。所有主干道都关闭了。现在，离开这个城市将变得很困难。
So we all go. We had a family meeting, and we're talking. And we were suggesting ideas. And my dad was like, nobody suggest anything. It's going to be my call. And we're going to go all the way south, as far as we can. Because if they're going to invade, the US troops will invade from Kuwait, from the south. So we're going to go to a point where we're going to be behind their lines as soon as possible. You know what I'm saying? He's like--
所以我们都走了。我们开了个家庭会议，商量点子。我父亲说，谁都别提建议。由我来决定。我们要一直向南走，尽可能远。因为如果他们要入侵，美军会从科威特，从南方入侵。所以我们要去一个点，我们要尽可能早地待在他们防线后面。你知道我的意思吗？他就像——
Yeah, no, absolutely.
是的，不，完全明白。
He said, they're going to pass us-- exactly. Exactly, he said, if there's a war, if there's an invasion, they're going to pass us in the early days. And then if they're going to siege Baghdad, or bomb Baghdad, or whatever, we're going to be safe.
他说，他们会经过我们的——正是如此。没错，他说，如果发生战争，如果发生入侵，他们会在最初几天经过我们。然后，如果他们要围困巴格达，或轰炸巴格达，或怎样，我们会是安全的。
So it was back in the car, this time headed in the opposite direction. And there was something new to worry about. The Iraqi army was looking for anyone over 17 to send to the front lines. They'd put up checkpoints on highways and bridges. Haider's father was too old, and his younger brother had yet to hit puberty. So if the car were stopped, it was Haider who was likely to be seized.
所以又回到了车里，这次朝着相反的方向。而且有一些新的担忧。伊拉克军队正在寻找17岁以上的人派往火线。他们在公路和桥梁上设置了检查站。海德尔的父亲年纪太大了，他弟弟还没到青春期。所以如果车被拦住，很可能是海德尔被抓走。
And my dad was very paranoid that I'm going to be taken away. And he had a plan. He was thinking of a plan. So what if we accidentally run through a checkpoint and they want to take you away? What are we going to say? My mom said, oh, we have to tell them that you're retarded. And you have to act retarded. And we're going to say he's retarded. You can't take him.
我父亲非常多疑，担心我会被带走。他有个计划。他正在想个计划。所以如果我们意外地经过检查站，他们要抓你怎么办？我们怎么说？我母亲说，哦，我们得告诉他们你是智障。你必须装作智障。我们要说他是智障。你们不能带走他。
And I was rehearsing in the back with my sister. I was rehearsing being retarded, basically. And I would, like, just have my tongue out. Like blah, blah, blah, and that kind of stuff. I mean, now it sounds funny. But at the time it wasn't. My sister thought it was funny, but-- I was talking to my sister, like listen, don't look at me if we ever get caught. Because I'm going to laugh if I see you laughing. So just turn your face off.
我在后座和我妹妹排练。我基本上在练习装作智障。我会把舌头伸出来。像咿呀咿呀那样。我是说，现在听起来很搞笑。但当时并不好笑。我妹妹觉得很好笑，但我……我跟我妹妹说，听着，如果我们被抓，别看我。因为如果你笑，我也会笑。所以别看我。
And I was talking to her. Then my dad stopped the car, and he turned back, and he said, listen, this is not a joke. This is your life we're talking about here. He literally said, this is not a show.
我正在跟她说。然后我父亲停下车，转过头说，听着，这不是笑话。这是在说你的生命。他真的说，这不是表演。
After a tense four and a half hours in the car, Haider and his family finally made it to a tiny tribal village in Diyala province, close to the Kuwait border. There, Haider's father had arranged with a family friend to stay as guests until it was safe to return to Baghdad. Haider unpacked his things from the car and introduced himself to the large countrified family who were now his new hosts. That night, crammed in the living room, they listened together to radio reports of air strikes across Iraq. The war had begun. The next morning, everything was different.
在车里紧张地过了四个半小时后，海德尔和家人终于到达了迪亚拉省的一个小部落村庄，离科威特边境很近。在那里，海德尔的父亲安排了一位朋友，让他们在安全返回巴格达前暂住。海德尔从车里拿出东西，向那一家淳朴的家庭介绍自己，现在他们是新的房东。那天晚上，挤在客厅里，他们一起听着伊拉克各地空袭的广播报道。战争开始了。第二天早上，一切都变了。
I remember I walked out of the house. And everyone was trying to get at the door. And we were looking down the road. And on the main highway there were American soldiers with the full gear. They were on one knee down, on the gunning position. And they were not moving. It was as if they were statues. And they just showed overnight.
我记得我走出房子。每个人都在门口争看。我们望着路。在主干道上，有装备齐全的美国士兵。他们单膝跪地，处于射击姿势。他们一动不动。就好像雕像一样。他们一夜之间就出现了。
At night, no one would go out, of course, because there were sirens. So when you can go out in the morning, you saw them. And they were not there the last time you checked. So it was like they showed out of nowhere. And the people were just staring at them. It was funny. It was like watching E.T. landing in your front yard. Seriously, that's how they were looking at them. People didn't know, should they walk down and talk to them? Should they be friendly? Should they not?
晚上没人出门，当然，因为有警报。所以当你早上出门时，你看到了他们。你上次检查时他们还没在那。所以就像他们凭空出现一样。人们只是盯着他们。很滑稽。就像看着《E.T.》降落在你的前院。说真的，他们就是那样看着他们的。人们不知道，他们应该走过去跟他们说话吗？应该友好吗？还是不应该？
I couldn't wait, actually, to go talk to them.
我实际上迫不及待地想去跟他们说话。
Very quickly, Haider got his chance. The Americans were the Army's Third Infantry Division. On that first night they had arrested two local imams. This did not go over well. Several villagers, including Haider's host family, approached the American army to plead for the imams' release. But something was getting lost in translation.
很快，海德尔就有了机会。美国人是陆军第三步兵师。第一天晚上，他们逮捕了两名当地伊玛目。这没讨到好。几名村民，包括海德尔的房东一家，接近美军请求释放伊玛目。但沟通上出了一些问题。
The Americans had an interpreter, an Egyptian. But he was having a very tough time penetrating the town's rural Iraqi dialect. Perhaps, the villagers suggested, Haider might be able to help. He spoke English well, and he had talked to Americans before. So Haider went to speak with the Americans and brokered the imams' release. He walked out of the base a hero.
美国人有一名翻译，是个埃及人。但他很难听懂城镇的农村伊拉克方言。村民建议说，也许海德尔能帮忙。他英语说得好，以前也跟美国人谈过。所以海德尔去和美国人交谈，促成了伊玛目的释放。他走出基地时是个英雄。
Later that day, a squad of American soldiers showed up at his door asking if he was interested in taking over the translator's job. It would be a chance for Haider and his family to get back to Baghdad with American protection. Haider was intrigued. His dad, not so much.
那天晚些时候，一队美国士兵出现在他家门口，问他是否有兴趣接替翻译的工作。这对海德尔和家人来说是一个在美军保护下回到巴格达的机会。海德尔很感兴趣。他父亲则不然。
My dad was totally against the idea. I loved the idea. I was like, of course. Sure. I'm going to go. And he was like, no you're not. I was like, yes I am. And he was like, no. And we were talking about it. I was like, listen, it's a good way to make money. It's a good way to have protection. And I want to go to Baghdad. And they will take me to Baghdad. I would rather be with them than be alone, because I'll be in the armored vehicles and stuff.
我父亲完全反对这个想法。我爱这个想法。我心想，当然。没问题。我要去。他就像，不，你不准去。我说，我要去。他就像，不。我们在讨论这件事。我说，听着，这是赚钱的好方法。这是获得保护的好方法。我想去巴格达。他们会带我去巴格达。我宁愿和他们在一起也不愿孤身一人，因为我可以坐在装甲车里什么的。
And he was like, you're crazy. No. He said, listen. Throughout history, whenever there's an occupation, whenever there are foreign soldiers, there's always a resistance. We still don't know how strong the resistance is going to be. We still don't know how ruthless it's going to be. So it's too early to take any sides. You should just not take any sides. Don't show that you are the American side. Don't show that you're with the resistance. Just don't take any sides now.
他说，你疯了。不。他说，听着。纵观历史，无论何时有占领，无论何时有外国士兵，总会有抵抗。我们仍然不知道抵抗力会有多强。我们仍然不知道它会有多无情。所以现在选边站还为时过早。你现在根本不应该选边。别表现出你是美国这边。别表现出你和抵抗力量在一起。现在别选边。
And that's how your dad had survived, right?
你父亲就是靠这样生存下来的，对吧？
Exactly.
完全正确。
That's how he had been so--
他一直就是这样——
And that's what he told me. He said, listen, I've been through several changes. And the only way I made it so far is by not joining sides when it's too early.
他告诉我的就是这些。他说，听着，我经历过几次变动。我之所以能存活至今，唯一的方法就是不在过早的时候选边站。
Haider was starting to realize that he and his father looked at life very differently. Haider's dad had always survived by being cautious, keeping a low profile. To Haider that sounded like a perfect plan for wasting away.
海德尔开始意识到他和父亲对生活的看法截然不同。海德尔的父亲总是通过谨慎、保持低调来生存。对海德尔来说，那听起来像是浪费生命的完美计划。
I would tell him that I would rather regret things I've done than regret things I haven't done. For him it was no. It was just if you have doubts about anything, just don't try. And then you won't regret it. Because you didn't try, so it wouldn't go wrong. Basically my dad would say that his ideology is, or theory is, to-- He would always say that you should climb the stairs step after step. Not jump any steps. Because if you jump, you can tremble and fall, and go all the way down the stairs. I jump steps.
我会告诉他，我宁愿后悔做过的事，也不愿后悔没做过的事。对他来说不。如果你对某事有疑问，那就别试。你就不会后悔。因为你没试，所以不会出错。基本上我父亲会说他的意识形态或理论是——他总是说你应该一步一个台阶地爬楼梯。不要跳台阶。因为如果你跳，你会颤抖摔倒，一路滚下楼梯。我跳台阶。
With the war, suddenly a new world had arrived in Iraq, with a new set of rules. And Haider saw it as full of possibilities for someone willing to stick his neck out. So he took the Americans up on their offer. And the family split up. Haider would ride back to Baghdad with the Americans in a Bradley assault vehicle. His father and siblings would stay behind. His mother would keep an eye on Haider, following the American convoy in the family car. About an hour and a half outside of the city, Haider saw smoke over Baghdad. And as they got closer, wreckage from the US assault.
战争发生后，伊拉克突然出现了一个新世界，有一套新规则。海德尔认为这充满了对愿意冒险的人的可能。所以他接受了美国人的提议。家庭分裂了。海德尔将坐布拉德利突击车随美国人返回巴格达。父亲和兄弟姐妹留下来。母亲将盯着海德尔，开着家里的车跟随美国车队。离城大约一个半小时，海德尔看到了巴格达上空的浓烟。随着他们接近，看到了美国袭击留下的残骸。
I remember when I saw all that, I saw all the military vehicles completely destroyed. We saw all the destruction, the houses, all the headquarters of the Ba'ath party knocked down. You didn't know-- you go back and say, oh but wait, that's my country. Oh but wait, that was my army. And this is not my army that I'm with. Who are these people then? And that's when you start asking that.
我记得看到这一切时，我看到所有完全被毁的军车。我们看到了所有的破坏，房子，所有被炸毁的复兴党总部。你不知道——你回去说，哦，等等，那是我的国家。哦，等等，那是我的军队。而我在一起的不是我的军队。那这些人是谁？那就是你开始询问的时候。
I remember, that's when I said, you know what? I want to be with my family. I want to be in the car. I don't want to be in the Bradley. It was not cool anymore. It didn't feel so cool. It felt weird. It felt awkward.
我记得，就在那时候我说，你知道吗？我想和家人在一起。我想在车里。我不想待在布拉德利车里。它不再酷了。感觉没那么酷。感觉很怪。感觉很尴尬。
And I kept going back and forth. I kept having these trials like, no, I should get over it. I shouldn't be so emotional. Saddam didn't represent me anyway. Saddam was not a-- it was not a democratic regime that we had. It was a dictatorship. So that wasn't my army anyway, or my country. But then you go, no, but it is. It was very, like, you had this conflict going on all throughout the roads.
我一直在反复。我一直在进行这些斗争，比如，不，我应该克服它。我不应该那么情绪化。萨达姆反正也不代表我。萨达姆不是——我们有的不是民主政权。那是独裁统治。所以那反正不是我的军队，也不是我的国家。但随后你会想，不，但确实是。这非常……你在路上一直进行着这种冲突。
Just a month before, Haider was working for Saddam Hussein. And now here he was, riding into town with the invaders. His father had warned him about picking sides too soon. And he was starting to regret the one that he'd picked. So shortly after he got back to Baghdad, Haider quit his job with the Americans.
就在一个月前，海德尔还在为萨达姆·侯赛因工作。而现在他竟与入侵者一起进城。他父亲警告过他不要太早选边。他开始后悔自己选的那边。所以回到巴格达后不久，海德尔辞去了美国人的工作。
Coming up, out of one dangerous job and into one that's probably even more dangerous. That's in a minute on Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International. When our program continues.
接下来，脱离一份危险的工作进入一份可能更危险的工作。一分钟后在芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际台。节目继续时。
[MUSIC - ALA HONAK" BY SAJADA AL UBAID]
[音乐]
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, stories of people discovering the big, wide, dangerous world. Gideon Yago's story about Haider Hamza continues.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，关于人们发现广阔、危险的世界的故事。吉迪恩·亚戈关于海德尔·哈姆扎的故事继续。
Haider spent his days at home. And his father, sisters, and brother had returned from the south. There was no running water in their home, no regular electricity in Baghdad. He was 19, packed in the house with his family, hot, bored, and with no exit strategy. If he was going to stay sane, he needed to get out of the house. So he decided to look for work as a translator. He got a job with Reuters, and later with ABC News. The city was cracking up into different factions. And Haider thought that working with the media was the smart thing to do.
海德尔整天待在家里。父亲、姐妹和弟弟从南方回来了。家里没有自来水，巴格达没有定期的电力。他19岁，挤在家里，炎热，无聊，没有退出策略。如果他想保持理智，他必须走出家门。所以他决定找一份翻译工作。他在路透社找了份工作，后来去了美国广播公司新闻部。城市正在分崩离析成不同的派系。海德尔认为与媒体合作是明智之举。
I felt that with all the chaos happening, with all the different parties being formed-- the Americans, the insurgency, the radical Islamists, the nationalists, Saddam's loyalists, the political parties, the Kurds, the Shias, the Sunnis-- all these parties being formed around you. Everyone is getting into groups. You either join one of these groups, or you need to get a protection. You can't be by your own. If you're alone, you're a very soft target.
我感觉到随着所有的混乱，所有的不同党派正在形成——美国人、叛乱分子、激进的伊斯兰主义者、民族主义者、萨达姆的忠诚派、政党、库尔德人、什叶派、逊尼派——所有这些党派都在你周围形成。每个人都在分组。你要么加入这些团体，要么需要保护。你不能独自一人。如果你孤身一人，你就是个非常软的目标。
So I thought my protection was going to be by working with the media. You have media badge, you're protected. You're protected by your organization, your network. You're protected by the US military and from the US military in the same time. I remember there was-- when they do a military operation, they just go raiding houses. My house was raided twice. Random raids. They broke down the door, because that's how they do it. I don't know why they never knock.
所以我以为我的保护是靠与媒体合作获得的。你有媒体证，你就受保护。你受你的组织、你的网络保护。你受美军保护，同时也受美军的监视。我记得曾有一次——当他们进行军事行动时，他们只是去突袭房子。我的房子被突袭了两次。随机突袭。他们撞开门，因为他们就是那样做的。我不知道为什么他们从不敲门。
They just kick down the door. They go inside, they start shouting and screaming at everyone. The power is off, and they have these torch lights on their rifles. And all you see is the lights running around. And you panic. You don't know what to do. But when they came into my house and they did all of this-- they knocked the door down-- I stayed in my room, waiting for them to come in. It's not a good idea to go out looking for them. You might as well wait for them to come to you.
他们直接踹开门。他们走进去，开始对每个人大喊大叫。电源关了，他们的步枪上有火炬灯。你看到的只是灯光在四处乱晃。你恐慌了。你不知道该做什么。但当他们进入我家做这一切时——他们撞开门——我待在房间里，等着他们进来。出去找他们不是个好主意。你最好等他们来找你。
So they walked into my room and stuff. And I showed them all my badges. And I said, I work for the media. Basically, you're just not like a poor Iraqi guy who doesn't know what to do, who doesn't know what his rights are.
所以他们走进我的房间。我给他们看我所有的徽章。我说，我为媒体工作。基本上，你就不像是个不知道该做什么、不知道自己权利的贫穷伊拉克人。
You're like an aristocrat.
你就像个贵族。
They would know that you're a journalist. You know what your rights are. You're going to go back and report all this. You have contacts in the media. You have contacts in the Iraqi government. You have contacts at the US military. So they ended up paying for the door they knocked down. They paid us compensations. They apologized. And they gave me a camel bag. That I just thought it was cool to have one.
他们会知道你是记者。你知道你的权利是什么。你会回去报道这一切。你在媒体里有联系人。你在伊拉克政府有联系人。你在美军有联系人。所以他们最终为他们撞坏的门赔了钱。他们赔偿了我们。他们道歉了。他们给了我一个水袋。我觉得有那个很酷。
But things were tense at home. While Haider was going out on assignment, the rest of the family was stuck in the house. His father was retired. His older sister had dropped out of Baghdad U. And his little brother and sisters had stopped going to grammar school classes.
但家里的气氛很紧张。当海德尔外出执行任务时，家里其他人被困在屋里。他父亲退休了。他大姐从巴格达大学退学了。他弟弟妹妹也停止去文法学校上课了。
Once again, Haider's dad would make noise whenever his son would come home about Haider's decisions, his job. He thought they were too risky, too public. Haider began to lie, telling his dad that he spent his days chained to some desk, filing papers, stuff like that. Instead, he was in the field, covering the Marine offensive in Fallujah or at interviews with heads of state in the Green Zone. Or covering Saddam's trial.
又一次，海德尔的父亲每当儿子回家时都会对海德尔的决定和工作唠叨。他认为风险太大，太公开。海德尔开始撒谎，告诉父亲他整天坐在桌前处理文件什么的。相反，他在前线，报道海军陆战队在费卢杰的攻势，或者在绿区采访国家元首。或者报道萨达姆的审判。
Then the city really started to go nuts. Remember the TV show that Haider had participated in at the beginning of this story, Bridge to Baghdad ? A few months after the invasion, the producers came back to tape a follow-up with the same teens, only this time, no Ministry of Information minders. They wanted an honest conversation, where the kids were free to speak their minds.
然后这个城市真的开始疯狂了。还记得海德尔在故事开头参加的那个电视节目《通往巴格达之桥》吗？入侵几个月后，制片人回来跟这些青少年拍摄后续报道，只是这次没有新闻部的监视人员。他们想要一次诚实的对话，孩子们可以自由表达想法。
The Iraqi teens agreed to do the show, but on one condition-- that it would not air in the Middle East. It was mid-2003, and the stances that you took in Baghdad were starting to have very real repercussions. The kids were assured that the show wouldn't make it onto the Arab airwaves. But somehow, without the producers at Downtown Community Television knowing, the program found its way on to Al Jazeera. For a week leading up to the airing, Al Jazeera heavily promoted it, using the most inflammatory clips from the Iraqi teens. Here are two, Saif and Waleed.
伊拉克青少年同意参加节目，但有一个条件——不能在中东播出。那是2003年中期，在巴格达采取的立场开始产生非常真实的影响。孩子们被保证节目不会进入阿拉伯广播。但不知何故，在“市区社区电视”的制片人不知情的情况下，节目上了半岛电视台。在播出前的一周里，半岛电视台大力宣传，使用了伊拉克青少年最煽动性的片段。这里有两段，赛义夫和瓦利德。
I've waited to say this word for 19 years. I hate this man.
我等了19年才说出这句话。我恨这个人。
Saddam Hussein, of course, everybody knows that he's a big torturist. We are glad to get rid of him.
萨达姆·侯赛因，当然，每个人都知道他是个大折磨者。我们很高兴摆脱了他。
We don't agree with him.
我们不同意他的观点。
There's actually nothing that bad in the show. Mainly Haider and the rest of the kids talking about how devastating the invasion and occupation had become. But Haider was nervous, particularly because the show ended with one of the teenagers playing a new song that he'd written with his heavy metal band. It was called "Saddam Sucks."
节目里其实没什么那么糟糕的内容。主要是海德尔和其他孩子谈论入侵和占领变得多么具有破坏性。但海德尔很紧张，特别是节目以其中一个青少年用他的重金属乐队创作的一首新歌结束。那首歌叫《萨达姆糟透了》。
I knew it was going to be aired now. I remember my mom also went in to pray that no one would watch it.
我知道它现在要播出了。我记得我母亲也去祈祷，希望没人看。
Pray for low ratings?
祈祷收视率低？
Yes. Exactly. She was praying that nobody has electricity. No one's going to be able to watch it. And I'm not going to get in any trouble. Then the way I knew that people did watch it, is that-- I think it was aired on a Wednesday night or something. On Friday morning, there was the Friday prayers, which is the big prayers for the Muslims. It's like the Sunday mass for Christians, basically.
是的。完全正确。她在祈祷没人有电。没人能看到它。我也不会惹麻烦。我发现人们确实看了，是因为——我想那是周三晚上播的。周五早上，有周五祈祷，这是穆斯林的大祈祷。基本上就像基督徒的周日弥撒。
So in Friday prayers, there is always a speech by the imam, just like there's a speech by the priest. But the difference, in the mosque there are loudspeakers. So for those who can not make it to the mosque, they will listen to the speech while they're at home. All you need to do is just open the window. It's really loud. I don't usually listen to the speeches that much. But it was there, and someone was shouting.
所以在周五祈祷中，总是会有伊玛目的演讲，就像牧师有演讲一样。但不同的是，清真寺里有扩音器。所以对于那些不能去清真寺的人，他们在家也能听到演讲。你只需要打开窗户。声音非常大。我通常不太听那些演讲。但它就在那儿，有人在喊。
And I was just walking around in the house, doing whatever I was doing. And then, suddenly I heard my full name in the speech. I was like, was that my name? And then, basically he was saying that a group of young Iraqis who claimed to be Muslims-- he didn't even call us Muslims-- have participated in a show on a channel of infidels.
我正在屋里四处走动，做着我该做的事。然后，突然我在演讲中听到了我的全名。我心想，那是我的名字吗？然后，他基本上是在说，一群自称穆斯林的伊拉克年轻人——他甚至没叫我们穆斯林——参与了异教徒频道的一个节目。
Pamphlets started to appear in the street with Haider's picture on them. Wanted posters. Threatening his family's safety and Haider's life. The day after the imam's speech, Haider came home to find his parents had packed his bags and left them at the front door. It was too dangerous for him to stay at home anymore. He moved into his office in the Green Zone for a while. Day in, day out, Haider's parents begged him to quit.
传单开始出现在街头，上面印着海德尔的照片。通缉令。威胁他家人的安全和海德尔的生命。伊玛目演讲后的第二天，海德尔回家发现父母把他的行李打包放在前门。他再待在家里太危险了。他搬进了绿区的办公室待了一段时间。日复一日，海德尔的父母乞求他辞职。
So I would always say, OK, one more month. OK, something's going to come up. I'm going to get an offer somewhere overseas. Something's going to happen, you know? And that was the only hope, because otherwise you would sit at home and hope for what? Maybe I'm going to die as well. That's the thing.
所以我总是说，好的，再一个月。好的，会有机会的。我会在海外得到一个职位。总会有什么事发生，你知道吗？这是唯一的希望，因为否则你坐在家里还能希望什么？也许我也会死。就是这样。
And yet before the war, there were certain red lines during Saddam's regime. You don't talk bad about him. You don't talk bad about his regime. You don't talk bad about his character. You'll be OK. No one's going to hurt you. You do, you die.
然而战争前，萨达姆政权期间有某些红线。你不说他坏话。你不说他政权坏话。你不说他性格坏话。你会没事的。没人会伤害你。你做了，你就死。
Now, there are no red lines. If there are, then they're invisible. You don't know what they there. You can be standing on the traffic light, and the car next to you goes off, and you die. Just a lost bullet goes through your head. You're driving and a US convoy shows out of nowhere, and they open fire, you get caught in the firefight and you die. You go shopping in the market, and a suicide bomber blows himself up, and you-- so it's not up to you anymore. It's not that you avoid certain things and you survive.
现在，没有红线。如果有，那也是隐形的。你不知道红线在哪。你可能站在红绿灯前，旁边的车爆炸了，你就死了。一颗流弹穿过你的头。你开车时美军车队凭空出现，他们开火，你被卷入交火就死了。你去市场购物，自杀式炸弹袭击者引爆了自己，你就——所以这不再由你决定了。不是说你避开某些事就能存活。
Haider ran this argument by his father. And his father said it was all the more reason to stay inside.
海德尔把这个观点告诉了父亲。他父亲说这就是更应该待在室内的原因。
Like he said, you don't go and jump off a bridge and you say, well, maybe I'll die, and maybe something-- a miracle is going to happen, and I'm not going to die. So if you hide at home, you have much higher chances of surviving. But I was looking at it as a slow death. To sit at home with no electricity, no water, fighting with my dad all day, that is slow death. That's how death is like.
就像他说，你不能去跳桥然后说，嗯，也许我会死，也许有什么——奇迹会发生，我不会死。所以如果你躲在家里，你有高得多的生存机会。但我把它看作是慢性死亡。坐在家里没有电，没有水，整天和父亲吵架，那是慢性死亡。死亡就像那样。
My world was much bigger than my parents' world. That was the problem. My dad's world is his home and his kids. It's not even the neighborhood, because he can not go out. That's his world. So that's why, for him, I mean so much, because his world is so small that everything in it just means everything. My world was much bigger. My world was like media, with globalization as a world. My world is like America, and Iraq, and Britain, and the coalition forces, and everything. That's my world.
我的世界比我父母的世界大得多。这就是问题所在。我父亲的世界是他的家和他的孩子。甚至不是那个社区，因为他不能出去。那是他的世界。所以对他来说，我的意思重大，因为他的世界太小了，以至于里面的每一件事都意味着一切。我的世界大得多。我的世界是媒体，是全球化作为世界。我的世界是美国、伊拉克、英国、联军，以及一切。那是我的世界。
So my world was much bigger than that. So will I give all this up and go to the much smaller, limited world? I can't. You can't. After a while, you can't. You just can't.
所以我的世界比那个大得多。那我会放弃这一切去那个更小、更有限的世界吗？我不能。你不能。过了一段时间，你做不到。你就是做不到。
So when it came to your dad trying to be a parent, did he even have a chance?
当谈到你父亲努力做个父亲时，他还有机会吗？
Well, that was the struggle. He had the feeling that he is not needed. I don't need him. I don't need a dad anymore, which I'm sure was not easy for him. And he would always walk up to me and say never give up having a dad. Don't-- he would literally use the term like don't put me on the shelf yet.
嗯，那就是挣扎。他觉得他没用了。我不需要他。我不需要父亲了，我肯定这对他也容易不了。他总是走过来对我说，永远别放弃有个父亲。别——他真的会用那种术语，比如别把我放上架子搁置了。
Haider kept working for two more years as a producer and translator, while all around him, the new Iraq disintegrated. Then one day, on a field assignment in Najaf, Haider finally understood what his father had been trying to tell him. He was there to cover Ashura, the annual Shia pilgrimage, which every year since the start of the war has come under attack with car bombings and shootings.
海德尔又做了两年制片人和翻译，而他周围的新伊拉克四分五裂。然后有一天，在纳杰夫的实地考察中，海德尔终于理解了他父亲一直想告诉他的事。他在那里报道“阿舒拉节”，这是什叶派年度朝圣活动，自战争开始以来每年都遭受汽车炸弹和枪击袭击。
And just a warning to listeners, this is where the story gets a little graphic.
给听众一个警告，接下来的故事有点血腥。
You know Ashura? Pretty violent. And there's a blast every year. And people know it. And you know what? That's what is sad. We go there. We know people will die. And that's why we go, so we're going to be there when they die. So it was like, I tell you there is a time bomb next door. And you say, oh, OK, great. And you go next door, and you set up your camera so you can film the time bomb when it goes off. And that's sad.
你知道阿舒拉节吗？非常暴力。每年都有爆炸。人们知道这一点。你知道吗？这才是最悲哀的。我们去那里。我们知道人们会死。这就是为什么我们去，所以我们会在他们死的时候在那儿。所以就像，我告诉你隔壁有颗定时炸弹。你说，哦，好的，太好了。然后你去了隔壁，设置好摄像机，这样你就可以在它爆炸时拍摄。那太悲哀了。
So they were going to say, OK, there's Ashura. People are going to die. You have to go and be ready. And get us a decent life position so we get good shots of people dying. That's the level that we got there. And we do it. And 3 million people gather. They know some of them are going to die. They still come.
所以他们会说，好的，有阿舒拉节。人们会死。你得去做好准备。给我们找个体面的位置，这样我们能拍到人们死亡的好镜头。这就是我们达到的水平。我们做了。300万人聚集。他们知道有些人会死。他们还是来了。
And I didn't tell my parents. My parents were like, if you're going to go to that, that's suicide, if you're going to go to that ceremony. Because people are going to die. You're going to be one of them. Don't go. I said, oh, I promise I'm not going. I had to go. I told them I'm going north, like just the opposite side. I'm going there to cover whatever, I told them. There was a golf field opened. They're opening a golf field on the US military base for the officers to go play with their cigars and stuff. And we did do that story, as well. But I wasn't on that team. So I told them I was going to do that instead.
我没告诉父母。父母说，如果你去那个，那是自杀，如果你要去那个仪式。因为人们会死。你会是其中之一。别去。我说，哦，我保证我不去。我必须去。我告诉他们我去北方，就在相反的方向。我告诉他们我去那边报道什么的。那儿开了一个高尔夫球场。他们正在美军基地开高尔夫球场，让军官们抽着雪茄玩什么的。我们也做了那个报道。但我不在那个团队。所以我告诉他们我去做那个代替。
I went down there. And the last day of December, we knew there was going to be something. All the cameras were rolling 24 hours, because we knew it was going to be any second, and we wanted to catch it. You see how crazy it is. So we were rolling, and it happened. There were seven blasts, a series of seven blasts in a row. About 400 people were killed. That's a lot of people.
我去了那里。12月的最后一天，我们知道会出事。所有的摄像机24小时滚动播放，因为我们知道随时会发生，我们想捕捉到它。你看看它有多疯狂。所以我们在拍摄，然后发生了。有七次爆炸，连续七次爆炸。大约400人死亡。那是很多人。
And I remember the scene, what you see when the blast-- when the bomb goes off. You actually can see the bodies just flying in the air. And I was down with the crowd at the time. I was looking at my trousers, my pants, and I saw all these tiny pieces of human flesh that stuck to you. I didn't know what they were in the beginning. I was looking. I was like, that's meat. And then I was like, wait a second. That's human flesh.
我记得那个场面，爆炸发生时你看到的。你实际上可以看到身体直接飞到空中。当时我和人群在一起。我看着我的裤子，我看到了所有这些微小的碎肉粘在你身上。起初我不知道那是什么。我看着。心想，那是肉。然后我想，等一下。那是人类的血肉。
One of the cameramen came in. He had a tape. I was sitting in the SNG just feeding stuff. And he came. He had a tape. And he had a nervous breakdown. He was like, blah, blah, blah. He couldn't talk. I was like, what? And he said, he died, blah, blah, blah. So I took the tape. And there was a scene, a horrific scene. A woman, she was Iranian, because a lot of Iranians come to the ceremony.
其中一个摄影师过来了。他有一盘磁带。我坐在SNG（卫星新闻车）里发送东西。他来了。他有一盘磁带。他精神崩溃了。他说，吧啦吧啦……他不能说话。我说，什么？他说，他死了，吧啦吧啦……所以我拿了磁带。那是一个场景，一个恐怖的场景。一个女人，她是伊朗人，因为很多伊朗人来参加仪式。
And she was-- you could see her holding her child, like from the armpits like that. His head was laying down. She was so silent. She was not crying, she was not shouting, she was not weeping. She was just quiet, looking around, holding her son. And her son is only-- he was cut from here. You can't see. Just from over the belt. And you can only see the flesh hanging down. And blood was just pouring down from his body. And she was holding him as if he was alive and he was a full body, although he's just half-child.
她——你可以看到她像那样抓着她的孩子，从腋下。他的头低垂着。她太沉默了。她没哭，没喊，没流泪。她只是安静地，四处看着，抱着她的儿子。她的儿子只有——他从这里被切开了。你看不到。只从腰带上方。你只能看到血肉垂下来。鲜血从他身体里流出来。她抱着他，好像他还活着，身体完整，尽管他只剩下半个孩子。
And she was in shock, that she was not reacting at all. She was not even looking at him. She was looking around as if she's looking and saying, what are these crazy people? What are these crazy people doing? And then I saw that. And what it was like-- I thought of my family right away. And I said, I have to call them.
她处于休克状态，她没有任何反应。她甚至没看他。她四处看着，好像在说，这些疯子是什么人？这些疯子在做什么？然后我看到了。那一刻——我立刻想到了我的家人。我说，我必须给他们打电话。
I called my family. And my mom picked up the phone. She was already crying. And she was like, I saw the news. I know you are there. She's like, are you fine? I was like, yes I am. And she was like, don't let me-- I mean, in Islam, if a person dies, his family has to wash the body before burial. She was like, don't let me wash your body one day. And I was like, I'm not. She said, I'll go talk to your dad. Your dad knows as well.
我给家人打电话。母亲接了电话。她已经在哭了。她说，我看到新闻了。我知道你在那里。她问，你还好吗？我说，我很好。她说，别让我——我是说，在伊斯兰教中，如果一个人死了，他的家人必须在埋葬前清洗尸体。她说，别让我有一天洗你的尸体。我说，不会的。她说，我去跟你爸说。你爸也知道了。
And I said, oh, I'm in so much trouble. I don't want to go back home. I did go back home. First, both my parents were hugging me and stuff. And then my dad grabbed me, and sat me down, and said, listen, one of these days I pass away, then it's your fault. It's because of you.
我说，哦，我有大麻烦了。我不想回家。我确实回家了。起初，父母都抱着我什么的。然后父亲抓住我，让我坐下说，听着，有一天我去世了，那就是你的错。是因为你。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
It means he was so worried about me, that if he's going to die of a heart attack or stroke, then it's because of me, and my job, and my lifestyle. And that for me was very-- I don't know. I didn't expect something like that to come out of him, actually. And, I realized--
意思是说他太担心我了，如果他死于心脏病或中风，那是我的错，因为我的工作和生活方式。这对我来说非常——我不知道。我真的没想到那样的话会从他口中说出来。而且，我意识到——
Why?
为什么？
I don't know. Maybe I was too self-centered at that point that I couldn't see-- I would think, oh please, what is all this drama? I couldn't see how crazy it was, what I was doing. I remember thinking, that was one of the things I considered the most of everything he said all his life to me. He's an older man. If anything happens to him, how would I be able to live with that?
我不知道。也许当时我太以自我为中心了，我看不到——我心想，哦拜托，这全是戏吗？我看不到我做的事有多疯狂。我记得心想，那是我一生中他对我说的所有话里我考虑最多的一件事。他是个老人。如果他出了什么事，我怎么活得下去？
Haider decided that he had to leave Iraq. An American employee for ABC who Haider had met during the Saddam trial told him about the Fulbright scholarship. It was a chance for Haider to study in the US for free. He applied and won. A year later, Haider was on a plane to New York.
海德尔决定必须离开伊拉克。一个在萨达姆审判期间海德尔认识的ABC美国员工告诉他关于富布赖特奖学金的事。这是海德尔免费在美国学习的机会。他申请并赢得了机会。一年后，海德尔坐上了去纽约的飞机。
I haven't seen my parents since last August. Though I know they're really proud. I know he is really proud, especially now. I know he changed, that he changed his thought about me. I think he's now wondering, you know what? Maybe he was right. Maybe the kid knew what he was doing. Maybe this is a different time. And I'm just the old school. And that doesn't work anymore.
我从去年八月就没见过父母了。但我知道他们真的很骄傲。我知道他真的很骄傲，尤其是现在。我知道他变了，他改变了对我的看法。我想他现在一定在想，你知道吗？也许他是对的。也许这孩子知道他在做什么。也许这是个不同的时代。而我只是老派了。那套不再管用了。
When he was 16, he chose to be a spokesman for Iraq. And now, living in New York, he finds that he's still one. His classmates and people that he meets always have a ton of questions about his hometown, what happened, and what's coming next. Though Haider says living in America on the Fulbright scholarship with the US government paying for his college classes, it's confusing.
16岁时，他选择成为伊拉克的代言人。而现在，住在纽约，他发现自己仍然是。他的同学和他遇到的人总是有无数关于他家乡、发生了什么、接下来会发生什么的问题。尽管海德尔说，靠美国政府支付大学学费的富布赖特奖学金住在美国，这让人很困惑。
I mean, it's very weird. I have a whole mix of feelings here when I came. After all, I'm in the country that's in a war with my country. And the same time, I love this country, and I wanted to come here for so long. It's my childhood dream to come to New York. But that was before America invaded Iraq. So that makes it very-- I don't know. It makes me feel weird. It makes me feel guilty. Do I fit here, do I belong here? I still don't know. I still don't know that.
我是说，这很奇怪。我来这里时有着复杂的情感。毕竟，我身处于一个与我国家交战的国家。同时，我热爱这个国家，我很久以来就想来这儿。来纽约是我儿时的梦想。但那是在美国入侵伊拉克之前。所以这使得它非常——我不知道。让我觉得很奇怪。让我觉得愧疚。我适合这儿吗，我属于这儿吗？我仍然不知道。我仍然不知道。
That story from Gideon Yago.
那是吉迪恩·亚戈的报道。
Act Two. Well, we just have time for one more quick story about heading out into the unknown of the big, wide world. Sally Goode was born blind. Filmmaker Tony Hill took her to a location but didn't tell her what it was.
第二幕。好吧，我们只有时间讲最后一个简短的故事，关于走向广阔、未知的大世界。萨莉·古德天生失明。电影制作人托尼·希尔带她去了一个地方，但没告诉她那是什么。
I can sense something in front of me. I can hear it in the sound. The sound changes as you're just walking around. This feels quite closed in. I think it's a wall in front of me. I'm just going to put my hand out. Yes it is. It's a brick wall.
我能感觉到面前有什么东西。我能从声音中听到。当你四处走动时声音会变。这里感觉相当封闭。我觉得面前有一堵墙。我要把手伸出去。没错，是它。是一堵砖墙。
We're walking up onto the grass now. Right, we are in front of a rather large object. A stone arch, about my head height. And another stone structure. This again is standing on a pedestal like a tower. This one is kind of cylindrical. A cylindrical tower this is standing on. And then it comes up to a long barrel-shaped stone object. Just placed on top of the tower horizontally. And then on top of it there's another cylindrical object placed vertically on the long the barrel.
我们现在走上草地了。好了，我们在一个相当大的物体面前。一个石拱门，大约和我头一样高。还有另一个石结构。这个又站在一个像塔一样的底座上。这个是圆柱形的。它立在一个圆柱形的塔上。然后它向上延伸到一个长的桶状石物体。只是水平放置在塔顶上。然后在它上面还有一个垂直放置在长桶上的圆柱形物体。
Bang. Lots of bangs going on. I don't know quite what's happening. But you can hear there are quite a lot of birds. Twigs underfoot. Well, well. This is quite a big rectangular, extremely tall, extremely wide stone block. Now I'm going to follow this and see where it goes. It goes a long way. It's going to the right now. It's a huge place. Off to the right again. I've just nearly fallen over onto the stone structure.
砰。有很多砰砰声。我不知道到底发生了什么。但你可以听到有很多鸟。脚下有树枝。嗯，嗯。这是一个相当大的长方形、极高、极宽的石块。现在我要跟着它看看它去哪。它延伸了很远。现在它向右拐了。这是一个巨大的地方。再次向右。我差点摔倒在那个石结构上。
The wall is now on our left, and I'm following it round to the left. It's just a great big, huge, stone wall. And a big metal [KNOCKING ON METAL] object. A cube-shaped object. Going way up, higher than me. I haven't the faintest idea what this could be. Following the wall again on our left. There's a bit sticking out there. That could be a door. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] No, it won't open. Hm, that's interesting. This is a clock. But I can't see where you'd wind it.
墙现在在我们的左边，我正沿着它向左转。那是一堵巨大的石墙。还有一个大的金属[敲击金属]物体。一个立方体形状的物体。向上延伸，比我高。我一点也不知道这可能是什么。再次沿着左边的墙走。那里有个突出的部分。那可能是一扇门。[听不清]不，打不开。嗯，那很有趣。这是一个时钟。但我看不出在哪儿可以给它上弦。
Following the wall around again to the left. We're on a path now. It goes in a little bit. We've reached a big-- ooh. There's an echo. Hello! We've reached a big wooden door. And the right of it is a handle. Just above the handle is a sort of a catch that you push down. A bit like on an outside door. Wall's coming around to the right again. All right. Another one of those metal cubular objects.
再次沿着墙向左转。我们现在在一条小路上。它进去了一点。我们到了一个大的——喔。有回声。哈喽！我们到了一个大的木门。门的右边有个把手。就在把手上方有个你可以往下压的门扣。有点像外门。墙又向右拐了。好的。另一个金属立方体物体。
And I found a window. I think that this could possibly be a church. The reason I say that is, sometimes church windows are like square shapes and diamond shapes. I think this possibly might be stained glass, which means we are by  a church. We're walking up onto the grass. And now a stone table on a big platform. [KNOCKING] And there's some more lettering here. And I'm trying to work, and find if it makes any sense to me.
我找到了一个窗户。我想这可能是一座教堂。我这样说的原因是，有时教堂窗户是正方形或菱形的。我想这可能是彩色玻璃，这意味着我们在教堂旁边。我们走上了草地。现在一个大平台上的石桌。[敲击]这里还有些字母。我试着工作，看看它对我是否有意义。
That looks like an S or a two. I'm not sure about this. It's a bit worn away. This is another stone structure. But I haven't really worked out what they're supposed to be yet. Oh my. The only other thing I can think of is gravestones.
那看起来像个S或2。我不确定这个。它有点磨损了。这是另一个石结构。但我还没真正搞清楚它们应该是干什么用的。喔天哪。我唯一能想到的就是墓碑。
Sally Goode, at the churchyard at Radbourne, Derbyshire. That story was produced by Tony Hill with thanks to Sally Goode and the Derbyshire Association for the Blind. Story is called A Sense of Place. Part of the Audible Picture Show, which is a collection of stories that they call a dark cinema. It is at www.audiblepictureshow.org.uk. Thanks to the Third Coast International Audio Festival, where we heard about this.
萨莉·古德，在德比郡雷德本的墓地。那个故事是由托尼·希尔制作的，感谢萨莉·古德和德比郡盲人协会。故事名为《场所感》。是《有声图片秀》的一部分，那是他们称之为“黑暗电影”的故事集。网址是 www.audiblepictureshow.org.uk。感谢第三海岸国际音频节，我们是从那儿听到这个的。
Thanks also today to Jon Alpert at Downtown Community Television, Michael DiBenedetto at Next Next Entertainment. Waleed Rabi'a, David Novak, [? Debbie Rothbert, ?] [? Michael Esse, ?] and [? Paul Bolester. ?]
还要感谢今天参与制作的市区社区电视的乔恩·阿尔珀特，下一站娱乐公司的迈克尔·迪贝内代托。瓦利德·拉比阿，大卫·诺瓦克，[德比·罗斯伯特]，[迈克尔·埃塞]，以及[保罗·博莱斯特]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight for our show, by our boss Mr. Torey Malatia, who just never can decide.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督，由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他就是永远做不出决定。
Maxi, mini, super , with wings, without wings.
大号、小号、超大号，有护翼的，没护翼的。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际。